my name is haralambo solomides
i'm a professor of pathology anatomy and
cell biology
at sydney kimmel medical college in
philadelphia
and the director of cytology at thomas
jefferson university hospital
this is my disclosure
immediately chemistry is the use of
antibodies
in tissue sections to react with
antigens to help with diagnostic and
research obligations
we use symmetrical chemistry to identify
tumors
to classify tumors to utilize prognostic
markers
predict response to therapy identify
biologic behavior
proliferation for example apoptosis or
metabolic activity
and identify infections and other
diseases
detection of the antibody antigen
reaction
is achieved either by immunofluorescence
the use of fluorescent eye or by an
antibody
conjugated to an enzyme that can
catalyze
a color producing reaction like in the
case of dab
here we have an example of
immunofluorescence and actually a
multiplex immunofluorescence
you have five different antibodies cd20
cd3 cd8
cd68 fox p3 and
at the lower right side
you have the combination of the five
different antibodies
you can see the individual antibodies
by using specific filters or you can see
the combination immunofluorescence
is used for decades it actually started
in the 1940s
right now is utilized predominantly by
researchers
and in the clinical practice we use
immunofluorescence in the cytogenetic
lab
specifically for the fish probes and
also for kidney and
skin pathology the advantages
is that this is a cheap technology
and also you can use many many different
colors that are available
the disadvantage is that you use
a dark room to review the slides
and also you have to have a specific
fluorescent microscope so this is not
available for the average clinical
pathologist
the immigration chemical state at the
present
uh is basically as everybody knows the
brown stain
this is what we use uh everywhere in
pathology
every pathologist is familiar with this
we use basically different antibodies
that they are mark in either the
membrane the cytoplasm
or the nucleus and this is how i we
identify
positivity in many big places
academic places for decades now they are
using double stains
these are combinations of two different
antibodies
and we're utilizing dab and the red
chromogen
to identify the two different
antibodies we take advantage of the
positivity
at different parts different
compartments of the cell
or the positivity at two different
types of cells that are mutually
exclusive
this is an example of a ttf1 knapsen
ttf1 being the brown nuclear stain
napsinate the cytoplasmic
granular red and this is for the
identification of the lung
adenocarcinoma here we have another
example p4pck56
for squamous cell carcinoma p40 being
the
brown nuclear stain and ck56
the cytoplasmic red
this is an example of identifying the
myobacillia layer in
lesions of the pressed proliferating
breast lesions
trying to make sure that we're dealing
with a benign
thing and there is no malignancy here
when whenever you see the myopitheal
layer intact
did means you are not dealing with an
invasive tumor
p40 and colponding p40b the nuclear
brown and compounding the cytoplasmic
red
very useful in breast pathology another
example
is trying to identify
different types of cells my epithelial
positive for nuclear p63 brown stain
and epithelial cells that are positive
for
calm 5.2 which shows you the
red stain on the left hand side
you can see the neoplastic process
and on the right hand side you can see
the benign salivary gland lms with the
ducts
and the async cells in this case we are
dealing with the benign
neoplastic process cleomorphic adenoma
another example of a double stain is the
cd x2 and ck20
uh widely used for identification of
colonic
adenocarcinoma again cdx2 the brown
ck the red
here we have a section from a prostate
and you see the resumes
is the cytoplasmic granular red stain
thus
that indicates the prostatic
adenocarcinoma
while the glands that are lined by
p63 and high molecular weight keratin
both of them as brown
highlight the benign prostate glands
so this is how you are using this
double stain which actually a double
stain but
three antibodies metastatic
carcinoma in the fluids
we have a double stain here that they
use
very commonly in our lab and this is the
verb for
caloredonine perform is an antibody
that stains epithelial cells but that
are not
mesothelial that means if you have an
epithelial cell
in the fluid that is not the mesothelial
said
by definition is malignant so uh
and the karenine is the red stain that
actually
shows you the benign mesothelial cells
present in your specimen
so double standard for correcting
for identification metastatic carcinoma
in cytology fluid so this is
what we are doing right now
and now we are going to talk about
possibilities
for the future um
[Music]
recently several companies have
developed
new detection kits and more chromogens
for making
a light microscopy chromogenic multiplex
a reality
i'm going to talk to you about the our
experience
at jefferson with chromogenic multiplex
at this time all these products that are
mentioned here
and the assays that we are talking about
are for research
only and basically
what we have done is
we we develop chromogenic multiple
classes
all the discovery ultra ihc
each staining platform using detection
kits
from in chromages from brush tissue
diagnostic
again this is for research only but i
think this is something that
may have and i believe they will have
some
clinical use in the future
so i'm going to show you examples from
different assays that we develop
first the quadruple four
color immunostains for the
classification of
non-small cell lung carcinoma then i'm
going to show you co-expression of
antibodies
with color colloquialization protein
expression
together with the dualish for hair too
very nice stain i think should have some
clinical
use in the future uh b and h is the
lymphomas that the rib driven
uh this will be like cd2 uh
or cd79a together with the
e-bear inside hybridization and we
developed also
a triple stain for metastatic carcinoma
cytology fluid by adding a third
marker the cd163 for macrophages
and i'm going to show you some nice
pictures about this
so let's start from the quadruple stain
for non-smart cell lung carcinoma
here you have four serial sections from
the same tumor
the same slide the same actual uh
paraffin block you have the ttf1 on the
top
next to nabsen showing you another
carcinoma component
p14 and ck56 at the bottom showing you
a square muscle carcinoma component
now the same the fifth slide
we did the quadruple
multiplex immunohistochemical stain
that basically shows you everything
together
instead of having four sections we have
all four antibodies
on one section and to make it on a
higher magnification you can actually
see nicely
ttf1 yellow knobs in a
is the purple cytoplasmic granular stain
p40 is the teal or blue
uh nuclear stain for the squamous cell
together
with the ck56 as brown stain
over here so this is basically
one section four antibodies you have
your
diagnosis another example
this is these are pictures from a very
recent publications few months ago a few
months ago we
we published this data
in the analysis of diagnostic pathology
we run a series of a cohort of 264
nosferatu carcinomas
of the lung stain them with the
quadruple multiplex and then we
try to come up with the diagnosis
we achieve very nice data and you see
here basically on the left hand side the
other
carcinomas you see on the
right hand side the squamous cell
carcinomas
and this is an example of a case that
had adenosuemos basically together
adenocarcinoma squamous
carcinoma clear cut and very easily
identifiable
with uh four markers at the same time
here we replace the brown with dab
and we have basically uh ttf1 yellow
naps in a purple teal as p40
and ck56 as the dab
so basically in the uh if you have the
individual stairs you have to go
back and forth back and forth try and
try to find the region that you are
questioning whether there is another
component
when you have all four together it's
much
more easier for you to identify exactly
uh where the mixed tumor is present
so this was a quadruple uh
multiplex for identification of uh
non-small cell carcinoma
the next thing we did is we we tried to
take advantage of the differential
strain of ck7 and ck20
those of you that are actually
practicing pathologies they know that
these are two markers that we use
try to try to figure out in cases of
unknown primaries
where tumors may be coming from
on the top you have ck7 as yellow
next to it is the ck20 as a purple
and at the bottom you have a tumor
that is positive for both ck 7 ck20
giving you the result of this orange
color uh esco expression of the
yellow and the pink
and purple now
why is this useful i mean for example
some tumors that are ck7 positives they
can 20 negative
lung for example breast upper gi
two mother ck 7 negative 20 positive
lower gi tumors that are seven positives
20 positive eurozillar carcinoma
for example um
or upper gi stomach can be positive
positive
and tumors that are negative negative
for 7 and 20
are tumors from liver uh
and of course the prostate
adenocarcinoma
so by knowing uh how the differential
state between these two markers
is you have a good sense where the tumor
of a known primary may be coming from
and you cannot additional markers to
nail
your primary um
this is the co-expression of antibodies
with
multiple colors a very nice example
of uh protein expression
together with inside hybridization is a
hair too
right now we practice uh
that the hereto expression with protein
image the chemical stain we do it first
we score it as 0 1 2 and 3.
cases with 0 and 1 are negative
cases with the score two are considered
indeterminate and we score three are
considered positive
the cases that are scored with
plus two we have to reflex it right now
to either fish for here too or
dual inside the hybridization with here
too
how about if we do this all together so
here you have an example of the teal or
the blue
is the protein expression of here two
and you have the hair to probe inside
the hybridization as
a silver or black what you see
and the chrome chrome
chromosome 17 is going to be the
red dot that you see in the nucleus so
by having this as a protein expression
together with dual inside hybridization
you basically achieve
the reflexes together with the original
original test at the same time
you can save time and you can actually
see exactly
where the questionable plus two cells
are
and identify uh the amplification of the
hair too
if it's present or not present so
protein together with the dual inside of
hybridization
another example of uh protein expression
and
inside of hybridization is we can have
in
in lymphomas here we have an example of
a teaser lymphoma
positive for ebv the markers are cd2
for the diesels and eber inside
hybridization for the abv the next
example
is a beastly format driven by abv
79a is that this is a diesel marker
and eberich is basically
the silver uh nuclear uh
that you see over here positive for ebv
fluids cytology fluids i showed you
before the
double stand that you are currently
using the clinical
practice uh per four with
reading here we added of course a third
color
and the third antibody that is the cd163
this is for a macrophage you can replace
that with 68
it's going to be exactly the same thing
so
you have a macrophage marker as
yellow in the background so you see how
many macrophages you have in your fluid
you have the teal color indicating the
mesothelial cells that are benign in the
background
and then you have you are purple showing
you the clusters
of the metastatic carcinoma
higher magnification everything is
clean and recognizable inflammatory
cells in the background
are just the hematoxylin counter stain
this particular tribal stain is is going
to be very useful
in situations where the tumor content is
very low
look at this field that we have on the
slide
there is a single small cluster of tumor
cells in the background
for this uh benign elements macrophages
mesothelial cells sometimes the reactive
mesothelial cells can look very ugly
easily make a mistake by this
triple stain you can very easily
recognize
where is your tumor higher magnification
you can actually see exactly uh so
making your diagnosis
much much easier
this is the same example of a triple
stain in the fluid
here we're dealing with a tumor that was
basically not clustering but were
predominantly
individual tumor cells that can very
easily be confused
with you know background macrophages or
mesothelial cells
different colors different antibodies
identifying different classes of cells
giving you very easily the correct
diagnosis
and of course uh i put these
two slides next to each other to show
you that you can actually play with
colors switch
colors on chromages on different
antibodies
and you can develop your own multiplex
depending on
what you feel is easier for you
so these these were examples of
potential usage of multiplex in the
future
that can be applied and be useful
in the clinical practice
now for research now for research things
are becoming
uh more interesting a little bit a
little more complicated
more complex we develop a jefferson
two five plex
five different antibodies together
five different colors the one as pdl1
cd8 fox p3 cd163
and mct4 you know about the pdl1
very important for immunotherapy cd8
diesel fox v3 basically the t-rex here
uh cd-163 macrophages mct4
this is a metabolic marker that we
decided to use in this particular
setting for this particular cohort
of what we are examining uh
the next five plex uh that we did
was for norse marcella carcinoma and we
decided to use just the
cd4 cd8 fox p3cd20
and a1 again these are research products
only
and these are examples of
our multiplex that were used in
different clinic
research settings at jefferson
we're going to talk about the first five
plex
uh this was uh employed in a cohort of
uh here the next grandmother carcinoma
to develop these five plaques we use
tonsillar tissue tonsil sections of
tonsils because
turn cells could actually give us a
positive control and a negative control
for pdl-1
it has a lymphoid tissue in the
background that is quite definitely have
a cd8s fox p3s cd 163
and we were sure pretty sure that we're
going to have cells with metabolic
activity
so we actually optimize
our five legs on tonsillar tissue
this is another example of tonsil
the p1 positive
cells in the crypts and here you have
different types of immune cells
on lymphoid cells that you have in the
tonsillar tissue
all right we evaluated
head and neck tumors some of them were
pl1 positive
some of them were pdl1 negative
and basically here you have an example
of a pdl1 negative
squamous cell carcinoma in the center of
the picture you have a
tumor cluster that is stained only with
the
hemodoxin background stain no other
stain at all
surrounded by cd8s
fox p3 and cd 163 cells
uh you know
the next example is the squamous cell
carcinoma that is pdl one positive
you have basically the positive tumor
cells staining with brown
surrounded here by cd aids
and macrophages we rarely see in any fox
p3 positive cell
so the the what we decided to
investigate here
was the micro environment of the tumor
so we had to choose areas that
are uh within the tumor you see here the
population
of immune cells that are present within
the tumor
on the left the side of the picture
and then you see basically on the right
side
tumor as well as the periphery of the
tumor
and you see a lot of
cd8s and fog speed three cells at the
periphery
near the edge of the tumor
this is an example of uh another
specimen from the same cohort
uh here you have a very metabolically
active
uh squamous cell carcinoma and evident
with the
positive mcd4 as a pink or
purple marker and again you see the
lymphadene filter surrounding the tumor
so these are good images nice images
and the question is how do we analyze
this i mean
what different measure can you get out
of these beautiful images
after i we perform the multiplex
we scan the images as a whole slide
image
on our scanners and then we use
an image analysis uh uh
basically from visio farm platform uh
and we developed together with visio
farm
thomas jefferson university and visio
farm we develop a private app
or a private algorithm to analyze the
concentration and the interaction of the
different cell types
in specific regions of interest in
relation to the mct4
and the pdl1 expression in the tumor
and the surrounding strong so that was
our goal that was what we decided to
examine here you have basically
our different parameters
pink or purple is the mct4
metabolic activity dab is a pdl1
expression
yellow is uh macrophage markers
uh 163 cd163
the teal or blue is the cd8
and the nuclear red is the fox p3 the
regulatory teasers
so as you can see
there are certain cells that are going
to be positive with more than one color
for example a macrophage can be positive
with a pdl one positive for mct four
and going to be made also positive for
cd 163
a tumor cell can be positive for uh
pdl one and mct four at the same time
so we're going to talk about this
further down the road
so what we do basically
is you have to define your regions of
interest
you have to annotate your slide uh
in the visio farm platform apply your
algorithm
and you're going to have a classified
image after
the algorithm is basically
run properly this is an example of a
section
of squamous cell carcinoma of the head
and neck
that we
annotate define the tumor area define
the marching
the matching can change i mean this is
an arbitrary
measurement you can have it at 20
microns
50 microns 100 micros is up to you what
you want to investigate
and then after the alkali is run you are
going to have
a classified image overlay that you are
going to have the different cells
identified that you are interested
and of course uh we set some
uh parameters here like we wanted to see
the interaction between cd8s and for hp3
so we measure the cd8 cells within 10
micrometers of four speed three cells
and also the cd8 cells within 10
micrometers of pdl1 pdl1-positive tumor
cells
so the goal was again to see the
interaction of the different immune
cells and the interaction of pdl-1
with some of the immune cells
after the the ab or the alkaline is run
the computer is going to tell you
uh concentrations of cells in specific
areas of the tumor
uh and it's also going to tell you the
distances between
specific tumor types depending of your
question
in this example it was cd8 for fox v3
and we have the different concentrations
of the different types of cells
in the different regions it looks
a little bit easy but in reality
um we have a lot of challenges
um basically the problem uh arise
because of the high cell density
overlap of cells staining
uh variability sometimes
the hematoxylin counter stains sometimes
we're interfering with the teal
color color color colorization meaning
cells that were positive with more than
one colors
creating a problem separating and
classifying them
and also macrophages we figure out that
the macrophage is a cell that has can
take different shapes
in the sections so it was a little bit
uh
interesting uh to classify these cells
because of their variation
the result of all these challenges was
that we have to spend
an enormous amount of time time
trying to basically uh make sure that
what the algorithm was using and
measuring was accurate
we have to do extensive annotations
repeat annotations uh reruns of the
algorithm
and trying to qa this slide based on the
eyeballing and make sure what we are
looking at is exactly what we
think we are measuring and
with all this in mind we got in touch
with visio firm
and visio farm
were nice enough to let us use their
artificial intelligence module and here
we're talking about a complete different
world now by using the artificial
intelligence module
things are much much easier
the initial is that that we experience
are extremely promising of course you
have to
train your ai you have to train with the
new algorithm
your questions and everything but in
reality
the result is much faster much more
accurate requiring
less quality control and quality
assurance
of of your results so uh this is
this is a superb thing that uh
i think this is the way to go we are
going to analyze complex
pictures complex images
with multi-parameter questions
nowadays ai is the way to go
of course you have to consider that this
is not the cheap proposal you have to
have powerful hardware
very good graphic cards and
and of course there is an initial course
in the
ai module so this
was our experience with the head and
neck
uh cohort that we run
a research that basically uh led to
several publications some of the came
already out some are coming out from
jefferson
so the next the next five plex that we
develop
uh is basically a multiplex
for non-small cell lung carcinoma
and again the question was
microenvironmental tumor
now we set up basically
a different set of antibodies
and we just evaluating cd4
cd8 fox p3 cd20 and a1 a3
the analysis of this now is much much
easier because
you have a complete separation of
everything
except the cd4 and fox p3
so these are basically different
populations that they have
a single color cd4s can be positive with
fox p3
but again here we take advantage of the
staining at different compartments of
the cell fox p3 is a nuclear stain
cd4 is a cytoplasmic stain so you can
actually teach your algorithm
exactly what you want to analyze and
what you want to measure
um the yellow color
used for a1 e3 was a requirement from
our researchers because they
they many of them were not pathologists
and they wanted to make sure that
they see exactly where the tumor is uh
when they do their measurements
uh and again we have uh purple as the
cd20
till or or
blue the the cd8 and the fox speed 3
is the nuclear red and you are going to
realize that the
nuclear red is always positive in the
cd4 positive set or a sub class of
a sub group of cd4 positive cells
that are going to be dab positive
all right and while we're playing where
this
we realize one very important thing this
is the exactly the same five plex
that i show you with the previous
picture
but somehow the uh the a1 a3 instead of
yellow
is orange what we use was actually the
yellow as well
so the difference between these two
multi-color images is the sequence
of laying down the colors which
basically
tells you that the sequence of
laying down your colors on the slide is
very important
if you put the yellow as the last color
is going to remain yellow
if you put the yellow as your first
color on the slide
is going to turn after applying
everything else
into an orange color the good thing
about this though
is that this is a constant thing
that means there is no sometimes going
to be yellow if something is going to be
orange it's always
an orange color if you put it first so
you can for purposes of quantifying
it doesn't really matter so these were
examples of
research applications for the multiplex
with
chromogenic immunohistochemistry
the advantages uh is that
you don't require a special microscope
you don't require to build the dark
this is uh something that can be
evaluated very easily by the practicing
pathologist
so even for research purposes this could
be a very
nice collaboration between researchers
and
practicing pathologists also now if you
think about it
you by looking at the slide
just by looking at it if you have a
multi-color
multiplex immunohistochemical slide
you are getting so much more information
just by looking at the single slide so
and it's very helpful in the diagnosis
of posit cellular specimens in cytology
is going to be an extremely important
thing
in a tumor diagnosis especially nowadays
that the tumor diagnosis is happening
with
my new specimens the specimen that the
first diagnosis is going to be made
usually these days is an fna or a small
core biopsy
and then the oncologist is required
so much information including molecular
testing from these tiny little pieces of
tissue
and this is where multiplex can be very
useful
with one section we can give them
classification you can give us so much
more information
not requiring many many sections try to
make a diagnosis
and and basically waste material so this
is
these are some of the advantages that
you can have with the multiplex
um in the future i you know the future
of pathology
we think about it is going to become a
digital pathology
so there are many
ideas about this and there is a lot of
talk about this
in 10 15 years from now or some people
actually say less
we're not going to have a microscope
we're going to have digital images
coming on our computer and those
pathologies we have to evaluate them
and and here is basically where
uh by adding multiplexing by adding
image analysis
by adding the ai modules you are going
to have
a tremendous information coming out of
the pathology department
in the near future that is going to be
so helpful for
the oncology and for treatments and
everything else so in other words
right now what do we see as pathologies
we see a slide
and we're giving a qualitative diagnosis
in the near future i think we're going
to be able to
quantitate continue our diagnosis and
give
a qualitative and confident quantitative
diagnosis at the same time
okay the disadvantages the major major
disadvantage here is that this is a new
technology
and has to be embraced by the practicing
pathologists
when i showed these images to
colleagues some of them they complained
too many colors are too confusing
so i mean this is something that
basically
we have to basically accept
the good thing is that the new
generation of pathologists the young
pathologists are extremely happy with
all these
uh possibilities that they're coming
down the road
the other issue here if we are going to
use multiplex
in the clinical practice uh then we have
to
to think about the cost some of the kids
are expensive
and reimbursement has to be an issue
uh basically this is something that we
have to
face regarding the
research components i mean you have in
addition to the immunofluorescent that
was basically the only thing that
you could do much deplexing nowadays you
can also
have a chromogenic multiplex
still at this point we have a limited
amount of
colors five six seven colors only
but i'm sure with the image analysis new
technologies
and uh new methodologies of uh
using how to use the chromogenic and
light microscope things are going to
change in the near future
so the most important thing here
is you have to have quality control of
what you are preparing
the chromogenic multiplex is a complex
assay and and really you can not have it
you know you you really have to pay a
lot of attention to your quality control
this is how you're going to keep it uh
you know at the forefront um
and at this point i want to thank my
collaborators
uh from thomas jefferson university
robert stop
uh help with image analysis uh
and the people that helped me with the
technical aspect
raymond and hildor the glaze jennifer
gregory and of course
our collaborators from roche tissue
diagnostic
my friend esteban roberts wendy french
larry morrison
and lauren peyman and at this point
we are done thank you very much for your
attention